[Music]
well golden knight fans are still
talking about last night's
big win over the sharks thanks again to
marc-andre fleury
sports director chris matthews joins us
live here in the studio with more
on the flower chris that's right thank
you very much christian i became a show
stopper here in the city of
entertainment mark andre fleury
has been the best player on the ice for
many of the knights games so far this
season
he comes up with so many eye-popping and
acrobatic saves
that really nothing surprises you
anymore last night's save on that
breakaway was just another
in a long list of saves that has his
teammates talking
flurry definitely providing a script for
what may someday be an award-winning
movie
the subject of the movie says hey don't
expect too much
i was sick i mean
the dude is just the man i mean what
else can you say like
me and rebo were talking about we want
to buy the rights to a movie about him
i don't think this movie is going to be
any good this
should just cancel that right now but
it's flattering
very flattering here but yeah
don't need it uh he is so humble flory
may get a break this week it looks like
backup robin leonard is about to return
he's been suffering from that concussion
but
he's back with the team they play
against the kings this weekend